un reto que permitirá crear grandes
oportunidades para trabajadores en todas
las naciones así fue como el presidente
de eeuu joe biden se refirió a la lucha
contra el cambio climático es una
oportunidad para crear millones de
trabajos bien pagados alrededor del
mundo en sectores innovadores trabajos
que traerán una mejor calidad de vida y
mayor dignidad para las personas que los
realizan
y el mandatario pidió que los esfuerzos
se centre precisamente en ayudar a los
trabajadores que han hecho parte de las
industrias que quedarán en el pasado
para garantizar su futuro y aplaudió que
naciones con las que eeuu tiene
tensiones en otras áreas muestran su
compromiso con acabar con la industria
del carbono me siento animado por el
llamado que hizo el presidente putin
ayer para que el mundo colabore y avance
en la eliminación del dióxido de carbono
y eeuu espera trabajar con rusia y otros
países en ese esfuerzo en la segunda
jornada del turno fue para líderes como
el presidente del gobierno español pedro
sánchez que celebró el regreso de
washington al acuerdo ambiental de parís
y el primer ministro de israel benjamin
netanyahu que se comprometió a que su
país no quemara carbón para
25 el encuentro en el que eeuu aseguró
que logrará la neutralidad de emisiones
en 2050 uniéndose a la meta de la
comunidad europea es la antesala de la
cob 26 cumbre mundial del clima que se
celebrará en noviembre en la ciudad
escocesa de glasgow en la que se
concretarán los anuncios hechos